begin
again with heavy hearts yet another mass
shooting this time at a medical building
in tulsa oklahoma police say four people
were killed and the shooter died by
suicide they have not identified the
suspect or his motive this makes at
least 20 mass shootings since the
massacre in uvalde last week that's 20
mass shootings since last week in each
shooting at least four people were shot
or killed reagan led better from our
tulsa affiliate kotv is following this
latest attack reagan good morning we
understand that there was at least two
guns involved
good morning nate that's right police
said the killer was armed with a rifle
and a handgun it was anywhere from 35 to
40 years old now what prompted this
shooting remains unclear but a tulsa
police captain called the medical
complex where this all unfolded a
catastrophic scene
it began authorities say just after 4 50
p.m when several people called to report
an active shooter at the saint francis
medical system's natalie building in
tulsa
around four minutes later law
enforcement swarmed the facility
on the ground and just after 5 p.m
police say they were directed to the
building's second floor where they heard
those shots tulsa police captain richard
muellenberg
as they were breaching that door to the
second floor of this building the
shooting suddenly stopped we have
four civilians that are
dead we have one shooter that is dead
and
right now we believe that is
self-inflicted police recovered a rifle
and handgun and said both have been
fired
but they could not confirm whether the
shooter was targeting a specific person
had to hide in the closet
and make sure that we were safe dominica
smith is a patient service
representative for saint francis she
says she was leaving her office in the
natalie building when security told her
to lock down and take cover
just fear
with all this shooting going on i've
seen it on tv this last couple of weeks
and it's just
startling to just have to go through
that and meanwhile in the nearby city of
muskogee police investigated an alleged
bomb threat they believe was connected
to the shooter but no explosives were
found after a search of the home in
question
captain muellenberg told cnn quote the
gunman shot with very specific purpose
but wouldn't elaborate further but
police scanner audio and at least one
witness suggests the gunman was looking
for a specific doctor who worked in that
building this is the second mass
shooting in oklahoma this week after a
gunman injured seven people and killed
one more in the city of taft on sunday
gail
boy reagan you put it all in perspective
very nicely the numbers keep ticking up
thank you very much